- While Maria was filming this movie,
she got some news about
a certain nomination
for her role in Borat.
And Judd actually got it on
camera, so let's see that.
(knocks on door)
- Where's Ron Junn?
- Action.
- You were just nominated
for an Academy Award, man.
- Ah! (beep). Oh my God! (laughing)
(everyone claps and cheers)
(audience clapping)
- You're so kinda to capture it.
I love that! You were, first of all,
why are you so scared at first?
- Because
(female guest laughs)
- Does he beat you on set?
- No! So here's the thing,
usually when we've been working,
Judd is gonna be incredible
and he's gonna say
on the mic some lines to
improvise and think about it.
And everybody can hear him,
but this time it was like action.
And I see that somebody's coming,
I'm like, oh holy (beep). It's
that bad that he is not...
- He has to walk over?
- ...comfortable to say it
out loud, people to hear it.
I'm like, how terrible. That was the scene
when we supposed to like
touch hands and hand
over hand, and my hands
are like shaking crazily
because I can see that
it's 12-oh-something,
it's time when the thing is happening.
He's coming closer, I'm
like, oh no, it's terrible.
And then when he said that,
and I was like, I don't really remember.
(all laughing)
- You blacked out. That's
so exciting though.
Congratulations, that's so exciting!
(audience cheers)
I love that it was on film!
That's so cool.